this video is sponsored by ubisoft let
me ask you a personal question
did you like breath of the wild okay
that was a rhetorical question because
of course you did but guess what
since you liked breath of the wild i
know you're going to love what i'm about
to talk to you about
introducing ubisoft's brand new open
world action adventure game called
immortals phoenix rising
i was lucky enough to be given the
opportunity to play this game on the
switch before its release by the buddies
at ubisoft and let me be the first to
tell you
i have genuinely enjoyed every minute of
gameplay
but let me explain to you exactly why i
have enjoyed this experience as much as
i have
as someone who initially was honestly a
bit on the fence about trying out the
game
i decided to give it a shot simply
because of the entire game
setup as in the in-game universe as in
greek mythology i don't know about you
but i am a sucker for a good delve into
the lore of the gods of olympus
and that's precisely what this game is
all about it's got all of the favorites
like zeus and athena and ares and
aphrodite and also the mythological
monsters like medusa or a manly minotaur
i personally feel like this focus on
mythology was a big reason behind the
huge successes of the franchises like
god of war so right off the bat i had a
good feeling about immortals
and once i started playing it's like
immediately i was
stunned it hits you as soon as you leave
the title screen with some charming
voice acting and character customization
you can look this way or that way or
have this voice or that voice
or this hair or no hair and once you
take your personalized hero
named phoenix with a y into the world
boy does it start opening up
right off the bat you're introduced to a
specific mechanic that i am personally
so glad to see again and that is the
ability to climb any surface at the cost
of stamina
i cannot stress how excited i am to see
this genius mechanic making its way into
more games because this is how you truly
unlock the feel of verticality in an
open world no i'm not overreacting as
you adventure through the game you
stumble across mysterious vaults that
feel
refreshingly familiar for fans of breath
of the wild that are full of puzzles and
monsters and normally reward your
perseverance with some sweet upgrades
like freaking wings did i mention the
wings yet because the wings are super
cool
there are tons of weapon and armor
upgrades defined in the game and another
awesome mechanic that again is just the
most
impressive thing in the world to me is
what i like to call transmogrification
no i didn't take that term from anywhere
why would you say that did you just find
a new piece of armor that stat wise you
should wear but you think it kinda makes
you look like a chump
well no sweat make that armor look like
this armor or hide it entirely
the world is yours to manipulate at will
speaking of which i mentioned earlier
that the story is non-linear right
because it is after you finish the
little beginning segment which is still
pretty open world
you can literally go anywhere at any
time
amazing and you know what's even cooler
immortals fenix rising is going to be
available on stadia xbox playstation the
nintendo switch which is what i'm
playing on right now
and pc so literally whatever you are
playing on on december 3rd you too
can experience this delightfully
charming adventure there are also some
pretty future-proof plans in place for
dlc
so along with the game there's an option
to purchase a season pass which includes
the next three narrative-based dlc packs
that will each include new
heroes and even branch into the world of
chinese mythology
and don't even get me started on chinese
mythology okay it's awesome but you want
to know what really puts the fun in
phenomenal
the combat if there's one thing most
will agree on with ubisoft games it's
the normally very fluid feeling combat
and immortals is no exception the setup
is that phoenix here can use three
weapons
a light weapon a heavy weapon and a bow
and you can switch in between them each
seamlessly in combat
there are also parry and perfect dodge
mechanics that enable you to slow time
for a bit to get some extra hits in on
an enemy and i personally like combining
this with some aerial combos for a lot
of damage the enemies are varied and
exciting to face off against
some of them will charge you head-on
some of them will throw things at you
spit things at you dive-bomb you from
the air
and the way that you deal with them is
completely up to you and i know what
you're thinking oh that's just some
basic combat setup that's been done a
million times before but can your basic
setup control an arrow as it flies
through the air
yeah i didn't think so imagine the
combat and puzzle mechanics that come
with that fun feature for spoiler
reasons i haven't even gone into what is
undoubtedly one of the coolest things
about the game
and that is the story which is
surprisingly much
better and deeper than you think given
the lighthearted nature of the art
direction and gameplay something that
took me a little bit to get used to
though that involves the narrative
is well narration which happens whenever
you do
pretty much anything you see prometheus
the titan is talking to zeus about the
story of phoenix that you are playing
through the entire time that you're
playing through it and like i said at
first i was a little put off by it but
it actually works out really well
and before too long become something
really fun that you look forward to
hearing whenever you face off against a
new enemy discover a new area or meet a
new face
the game also has some pretty great
quality of life features like a photo
mode
auto run and customizable controls i
think it's safe to say that i am a firm
believer in this game and i'm actually
very grateful to have been given the
opportunity to test it out and i
honestly think it's going to be a big
hit
it's got this laid back colorful
stylized eccentric vibe about it while
not doing away with some of the biggest
factors for what makes it a good game
also did i mention yet that the scenery
and lighting in this game is absolutely
gorgeous even on the nintendo switch and
with the game releasing on said switch
you can literally play immortals on the
go in the car
at your tv in bed or anywhere else but
if you had another platform in mind then
have no fear because like i mentioned
earlier this game is available on the
xbox one xbox series x ps4
ps5 google stadia the pc and of course
the nintendo switch
so whatever you're gaming on click the
link in the description below to start
your charming adventure in the world of
immortals phoenix rising today once
again huge thanks to the friends at
ubisoft for sponsoring this video and
letting me have fun with immortals
phoenix rising i truly hope that you
will too
as always thank you so much for watching
and if you do end up picking up the game
or just have a few general thoughts
about it let me know what you think in
the comments below
i hope you have a phenomenal rest of
your day and of course this is masentena
bennett signing out
peace
[Music]
now